hey everybody fallout 76 has been
officially announced we're gonna see
more at e3 but right now we're gonna
talk about what we know and what we're
hoping to see from it so from the
trailer and from the lore of fallout we
know that the vault is opened 20 years
after the bombs it has 500 people and
the ideas that they were supposed to be
the first settlers to reclaim the
wasteland yeah it is the earliest
Fallout game in terms of timeline yes
like I think the first one takes place
50 years after the bombs drop I think I
could be wrong
50 or 80 so yeah somewhere around there
so this is 20 this is the earliest one
yes and you can see like on the pip-boy
it looks like the pip-boy 2000 from the
earlier ones a little different but it's
kind of going for that like earlier Tech
design so that's the trailer didn't
really say much else there's a lot of
like hidden information I know we have
plenty of breakdowns too that you can
check out and check out we're not gonna
do that we're just gonna more talk about
the rumors which Kotaku has talked about
some other people have mentioned that it
is going to be a online survival game
yeah in a similar vein to dayz or rust
or something like right which I think my
first when I first heard that I was like
I don't know if I want Bethesda Game
Studios doing something like that
however after thinking about and talking
about in the office I actually think
like if they are gonna do a game like
this fallout fits really well and I
think they could do it properly right
I've always felt like follow as a
universe is actually like really primed
for spin-offs and I've always wanted
them to like experiment with different
style Fallout games so I'm all for this
and they've mentioned in the in the
Kotaku thing it mentioned that there was
still gonna be quests and there's still
gonna be a main story so it's not like
it's gonna be like you're just running
around aimlessly there's still things to
do in dialogue yeah which i think is
definitely important when considering
these kind of games because a lot of
times the issue is is that apart from
those PvP interactions there's not a
whole lot to do right so I guess the big
thing is sort of like how many people do
you think are gonna be playable like is
it it's the idea like it's one big
server I mean in the in the lore it's
five hundred people in the vault so it's
gonna be 500 people in one server do you
think like how do you think they're
gonna handle that five hundred people in
server would be ambitious yeah I agree I
can't imagine it would be like that and
I'm also curious if everyone you
interact with is gonna be from vult 76
like yes that's what it's called so
probably but that also seems kind of
weird that you'd be interacting with
people that you spent 20 years with
already so it's like would you
necessarily like shoot someone who you
lived in the vault with for 20 years
like I'm curious how that's gonna work
yeah like do you all start as vault
dwellers or can you like be like I'm
gonna play Raider or I'm gonna play like
a mute movie yeah I'd be interesting
because I feel like when you when you
take a game like fallout it's very it's
designed to be you can mess around with
it you can like build whatever you want
you can you know kind of go crazy you
can kill anyone you want yeah you become
a drug addict so you can like right do
all sorts of weird roleplay I'm very
curious to see how they're gonna handle
that with online cuz you know you think
of like games like dayz and rust and
kind of what they were talking about and
those games were designed a lot around
like trolling and ganking I would hope
they'd have a way where it's like I want
to play this game and not feel like I'm
constantly at risk of losing all my [ __ ]
did I do like the idea of that but I do
feel like there needs to be some sort of
safety net yeah I think the easiest
workaround and I think what will
probably be the case is that there will
be public servers where you can interact
with random people and then and also
have your private servers where you can
just play with friends you can explore
the wasteland do quests hopefully ya
build like because the wasteland is such
a threat as is that you don't
necessarily need other people I feel
like to get involved well that
definitely adds an extra layer and well
I'll definitely spend time doing that if
all that seems also the perfect game to
just do co-op you know like yeah pee-yew
me a couple other people are just in a
server we set up some buildings some
establishments fight off some super
mutants some razor razor claws with what
are they called again DEFCON deathclaws
so yeah it seems like it wouldn't make
sense what I'm most curious about how
they're gonna how they're gonna
interview the story right I think maybe
the thing that makes me the most excited
about this is you and me we're playing
the forest mm-hmm which
a co-op survival game with a story and
I'm thinking about like those that was
so much fun and that like that was maybe
the first game of this type of survival
game style that I ended up like really
really yeah
liking and if this game can kind of
capture that feel of like you're working
together with your buddies and you're
building a shelter and you're like
fighting off like enemies and you're
doing quests but it's in the Fallout
universe I think this game could be
something really yeah and I hope they
really I mean because it makes so much
it makes so much sense for Fallout but I
hope they really take advantage of the
genre and that you need to eat you need
a drink and like they've in Fallout New
Vegas they added that hardcore mode and
in Fallout 4 they eventually added it it
was a shame that it wasn't at launch
because I ended I'm not spending any
time with it but I always felt those
were the best ways to play fallout
because that really puts you in the
shoes of a someone who's trying to
survive the apocalypse or you
post-apocalyptic world so I really hope
they embrace that sort of design and you
are forced to scrounge for food scrounge
for water and though like I hope that
plays a huge role me too and those other
modes always felt a little tacked on
because it was still it's like a
modification of the basics exactly yeah
so if they design it from the ground up
I think they could really improve on it
and that would be really cool yeah I
hope you're not a slave to those systems
though because that can also become an
issue with these kind of games totally
alright guys so that's everything we
know about fallout 76 and what we want
to see that game is going to be at e3
which we're going to be covering so make
sure to tune back in for that
[Music]
in both 76 our future begins